the most degrading offensive
assumption-filled question that i get
asked
way too often mostly on social media but
perhaps maybe even in real life is
i live a very weird life i've spent over
10 years studying to become a doctor
and when i finally became one i split my
time between the hospital
and social media and media so there's
not many doctors out there like me and i
want to share with you
what it's like being a doctor youtuber
media personality
what does that all mean what challenges
do i face and most importantly
answer some of your most frequently
asked questions
[Music]
i am a real doctor i mean i get that
asked all the time
it would happen a lot more when i was in
residency training but now
still when i tell people what i do like
but are you a real doctor
i'm a true family medicine physician
board certified i keep up with
my licenses both in new york and new
jersey even though i do most of my
practicing in new jersey
i work half the week in an outpatient
family medicine
center i actually have done a full day
in my life video
that's linked down below and i'm
actually in the process of shooting
another
day in my life in the coming weeks i'm
really excited to share that with you
for those of you who don't know being a
family medicine doctor means i treat
patients of all ages
for all types of conditions and why i
love the field of family medicine to be
in the media spotlight
is because we have to be able to talk on
all different types of subjects
we have to digest information from
specialists complex information from
specialists
really quickly and make it easily
understandable for my patients
i also have to predict what questions my
patients have
often times that intersect with the
questions that you have
so i think the more i practice in being
a doctor in real life
the better i become on youtube but at
the same time
the more time i spend researching
different subjects for
youtube the more value i bring to my
patients it's like one hand
truly does feed the other
[Music]
people will see me getting out of my car
and say oh you're dr mike hey dr mike i
have this thing
do you think i need to go get it checked
out not only is that unethical
that they're doing that because you
can't really make a good diagnosis
in that uh setting but it's also kind of
like an invasion of privacy that i
never expected to face when we're in med
school we're actually
trained to deal with something known as
cocktail medicine
and cocktail medicine is when you're at
a bar with a friend
and they say hey you're a doctor let me
pick your mind about something you have
to be very clear and specific that
you're not establishing a doctor-patient
relationship
because when you do that you're actually
becoming liable
for the results that they experience in
taking your advice
so you learn how to straddle this line
of explaining that you're speaking in
generalities you're not giving direct
advice
and i've gotten better over time in
doing this that's why i was able to
launch my curbside consult series
where i literally run around the streets
of new york city answering people's
questions
and i've leaned into this uncomfortable
uncertain situation
and the more that i've done that the
better i've become and the less stress
it's taken off of my shoulders
[Music]
now this is very very difficult but also
really important to the integrity
of me as a physician unlike most
influencers or most celebrities when
they give advice they're giving advice
personally but i'm giving advice not
only personally but as an expert
so i need to understand that the weight
of my message
is higher than that of a traditional
influencer and i need to put that extra
level of integrity on top of it so
you'll
never see me advertise something that i
truly do not believe in
or that evidence-based science doesn't
stand behind as well
being financially successful is great
but i'm never going to do that at the
expense of my patients
or you my viewers
[Music]
my relationship with my patients has
absolutely
changed since i became popular but it's
changed for the better these are
hypothetical based on true examples
patient a is a 26 year old female that
has never went for a preventive health
checkup that has now come in
and gotten her first pap smear with a
family medicine doctor
because she felt comfortable after
watching a few of my videos guess what
we found an irregularity on that pap
smear we're able to act upon that
and prevent a case a potential future
case of cancer
second example i have patients who are
looking to lose weight
and they want to do it in a healthy way
they want to see what options they have
sometimes we run out of time in a visit
and they say doctor do you have more
resources for me to look at i trust your
opinion well now i can direct them to
videos on my channel they can watch
those videos
pick up little tidbits and on the next
visit they can bring me their list of
questions so that i can answer them
and they can make the best decision for
what works for them and the third
example when a patient
doesn't know they're going to see me i
walk into the room and they
freak out because they're like oh my god
i was just watching one of your covet 19
videos or i was watching
one of your grey's anatomy reviews and
now you're my actual doctor
and they're just so much more dialed in
on that visit
they're excited they want to take
control of their health i mean
that is what every doctor wants from
their patients
for them to be get excited about health
literacy to learn about what medications
they're taking
what preventive things they should be
doing to improve their health
and when someone watches that on my
channel and then sees me in the office
that motivation goes through the roof
that's one of those things that brings
me so much joy
because it oftentimes happens in the
pediatric population
so when i see a 10 year old who's
struggling or a 13 year old who's
struggling in school getting bullied
perhaps
and they feel comfortable talking to me
about their mental health struggles or
what's going on at home i consider that
a
major major win
[Music]
when it comes to being someone who has a
lot of followers there's going to be
things that we all share in common with
that unique group of people like
i even talked about it with emma
chamberlain on the channel that
interview is linked down below
people recognize you they make
assumptions about you they think they
know you simply because they saw you on
the youtube channel when it comes to
being a popular person i think for me
one of the things that people talk about
most often is the loss of privacy
that's absolutely true people are really
involved in your personal life whether
it's digging through your relationships
your past relationships
what's going on in your family life
sometimes that gets quite
weird especially when emails start
getting sent around
to you know friends relatives
i mean the amount of fake accounts on
social media
using my face or my name is incredible
please do not fall for it
look for the blue verified check mark
all my accounts are verified the sad
part about it is they oftentimes cheat
people out of money
by pretending to be me getting them to
send pictures
share intimate things about their life
even getting financial
benefits from doing so another thing
that happens is
negative comments trolls uh death
threats
i choose not to focus or dwell on it so
much i also think that
i'm lucky there's a lot of positivity on
the channel
thanks to you i think i approach a lot
of these very difficult issues with
empathy it doesn't trigger as many
people to come after me in a hateful
type of way
i hope to continue this moving forward
in the future where we have
more fruitful discussions less hate less
trolls but at the end of the day we just
have to expect for that to happen
take it on the chin and move on because
as
jonathan heights said on this channel we
have to become
okay with being treated
unfairly or poorly i'm probably mincing
words but it's something
similar to that and i very much agree
with it
and being someone who was picked on a
lot growing up
i think i've learned how to handle that
well and use it in a positive way to
motivate me to help me improve
because ultimately that's what we all
need to do if we want to get
further in life
[Music]
i studied over 10 years to get here i
did it
because i love it i'm passionate about
it nothing will ever replace
the joy that i feel in being in a room
with a patient helping them
being one on one being in that moment
the most
degrading offensive assumption-filled
question that i get
asked way too often mostly on social
media why did you become a doctor when
you could have been a model
as if those two careers are
interchangeable when you ask that
question you're almost making the
assumption
in saying you can't be a doctor who's
also good looking or you can't also be a
model
and be smart at the same time i actually
just got a few dms the other day
from female doctors who were saying that
they're struggling with that same thing
the issue that people aren't taking them
seriously
because they are beautiful why
judging someone based on their looks is
useless in fact i pride myself
on proving people wrong in that in high
school i was the president of the math
and science institute
it was one of like the most highly
regarded uh
types of classes that we had in our
school because that i had to go to the
principal's office for a meeting every
three months when i'm sitting in the
principal's office i was dressed
kind of gangster because that's how i
like to dress baggy clothes
jeans like falling off of my hips that
was a style back then i was really into
it principal walks into the room and
says
uh what are you here for detention i was
like no i'm actually here for the math
and science institute principal's
bi-monthly meeting i'm actually the
president as well
the look on her face gave me goosebumps
i love that feeling and i encourage
those who are facing
discrimination for looking a specific
way to try and
use that to energize them or better yet
something that i've learned over time to
do
just prove people wrong with your
results
put blinders on get to where you need to
be if
someone is being discriminatory because
of the way you look that's a whole other
issue and you actually you should
absolutely address that but if someone
says oh you know you're too beautiful to
do this
brush that ish off move on
and crush with your knowledge and
experience check out this
hilarious tiktok video or my recent
memes video that you may have missed
and as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]